>>>EEK 17
HAPPNF SUND,EVYBODND
HAPP N YR TYOYOSTPEOTIDETHAC REA
ATOIGR
W LIN  NYEEE, NN
EL RYOD
TU, NG GN TH COMNTSIGHT W.IM IN.
I SEMY G W. TRAELLN TH
MMEN RIGW.
WHAT HAENIN
YOU E WAINGAY WH A
ODIE
SHOUOUT  EVEBODYN TH
MMEN.IT MADVE.
PPY W AR'S EVYBODLEGEHIHI GO>>'O
Y'TNOHEEAY
W, U'UN O O TI A IEE ND A INORCK
OO TDO
ORWE Y EEKSK YCI O'GEG HE ZO.
ANDET'S TAK AOO AT T TOP
CHOIS TH WE RECEED.
OPERUPPNDAVAN ADA, TH HAVBEEN B
DE Y LOT O MEYF YOU
HAVE BET ON THEM EACH AND EVERY
WEEK WITH THEIR PROPS.
J.T. ONE OF THE ONLY
NONQUARTERBACKS THAT'S BEEN IN
THE MVP RACE THIS YEAR.
TRAVIS KELCE HAS GOTTEN IT DONE
DOWN THE STRETCH AND A LOT OF
BIG PLUS MONEY.
WILL ANY OF THEM MAKE AN
APPEARANCE?
I THINK THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE IS
WONDERING RIGHT NOW.
GREG, LET ME KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE
GOT IN STORE TO GIVE AWAY TODAY.
>> EVERYBODY HERE, LISTEN UP.
I'M NOT ONLY GIVING AWAY HOODIES
TODAY, BUT I'M ALSO GIVING AWAY
TWO.
NOT ONE, BUT TWO NFL JERSEYS.
ONE TO THE LUCKY LOCK LEGEND
WINNER OF THE LOCK LEGEND
TOURNAMENT AND ONE TO A LUCKY
COMMONER LIKE YOURSELF.
SO DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
STICK AROUND, GET SOME WINNERS.
AND THEN YOU'LL POSSIBLY WIN A
JERSEY.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, I NEED
GIFs.
I NEED EMOJIS.
BUT, CONNOR, ON THIS SHOW, WE
WANT WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
AND THAT'S WHAT I NEED IN THE
COMMENTS.
YOU GUYS, FILL THEM UP.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE NEED WINNERS AND WE'RE GOING
TO FIND ONE TODAY BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE SQUAD RIDE TOURNAMENT.
THE LAST MAN STANDING, LAST PET,
FARM, ANIMAL, WHATEVER IT MAY
BE, THEY TAKE HOME THE NFL
JERSEY GIFT CARD AND THE TITLE.
THE MAN NEXT TO ME IS GOING TO
BOOST THOSE ODDS.
LET'S NOT WASTE ANY TIME AND GET
RIGHT INTO IT WITH THE FAMILIAR
FACE IN W. TRAMMELL.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE LOCK OF THE
WEEK IS, W. TRAMMELL.
>> WHAT'S UP BR NATION?
WE'RE BACK WITH LUCY.
LET'S SEE IF SHE'LL FIND US IN
THE SNOW.
A.J. DILLON, LOCK IT IN.
>> NEW YEAR BUT SAME RULES
APPLY.
DO NOT FADE LUCY.
LUCY GOING WITH SOME BIG PLUS
MONEY HERE.
PLUS 220 FOR A.J. DILLON.
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE ON A
CHALLENGER RIGHT HERE.
WE GOT BETTING LOOKING TO KNOCK
OFF LUCY.
LET'S SEE THE PICK.
>> HEY, BLEACHER REPORT BETTING.
I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG 2021.
BUT THERE IS ONE THING WE ALL
WANT TO START 2022 WITH, A GOOD
BET.
THAT'S WHY MY PICK FOR THIS
SUNDAY IS KENDRICK MOORE IN THE
PATRIOTS GAME.
>> THE MAN WITH THE PATRIOTS HAT
GOING WITH THE PATRIOTS.
THEY GOT THE JUICIEST MATCHUP.
WE GOT LUCY HERE GOING WITH THE
CHEESE.
WE GOT OUR HELMET LEGEND FRIEND
GOING WITH KENDRICK BOURNE.
PLUS 180, PLUS 220.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST PLUS
MONEY ROUNDS WE'VE HAD IN A
WHILE, GREG.
LET THEM KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO
DECIDE.
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME
KNOW.
IF WE'RE ROCKING WITH A.J.
DILLON, WE'RE ROCKING WITH MY
GUY KENDRICK BOURNE.
I WILL JUMP RIGHT IN HERE.
JONES IS PLAYING TODAY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT A.J. DILLON.
NINE ATTEMPTS LAST WEEK.
SEVEN ATTEMPTS THE WEEK BEFORE
THAT.
THIS ONE SEEMS A LITTLE RISKY TO
ME, CONNOR.
EVEN THOUGH I KNOW HE'S TAKING
ON THE VIKINGS DEFENSE, THEY
GAVE UP OVER 100 YARDS RUSHING
ALL OF DECEMBER.
WE KNOW THAT THE PACKERS LIKE TO
RUN THE BALL.
THEY LIKE TO ESTABLISH THE RUN
TO GET AARON RODGERS GOING.
THIS ONE JUST SEEMS A LITTLE
RISKY TO ME, CONNOR.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT K.B.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MY GUY KENDRICK
BOURNE.
HE HAS FIVE TOUCHDOWNS ON THE
SEASON, BUT HE HASN'T SCORED
SINCE NOVEMBER 28th, CONNOR.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
PEOPLE AT HOME DO NOT BE
ALARMED.
IT ONLY MEANS THAT HE IS DUE,
AND THEY'RE TAKING ON A
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS TEAM.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A STAT GAME
FOR EVERY OFFENSIVE PLAYER ON
THE PATRIOTS ROSTER.
THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THIS
GAME AS A STAT GAME.
SO GIVE ME K.B.
>> I LIKE WHERE YOU'RE GOING,
GREG.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A.J. DILLON, I
THINK HE'S ONLY SCORED IN
GENERAL FOUR MORE WEEKS THIS
YEAR.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD SAMPLE SIZE
FOR A REALLY GOOD PLAYER.
IT IS THE TOTAL THAT YOU ARE
GETTING.
TARGETS, CARRIES.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS ON HIS
BEST DAYS HE'S SPLITTING THOSE
UNLESS THERE IS AN INJURY.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE, LIKE WE
SAID, GREG.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THE MATCHUP
HERE.
I WILL GO WITH KENDRICK BOURNE
AS MUCH AS NEW ENGLAND MIGHT RUN
DOWN THEIR THROATS ALL DAY.
THEY PROBABLY CAN.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT IS
SUCH A GOOD MATCHUP.
YOU NAILED IT THAT HE'S DUE.
THESE ARE BIG PLUS MONEY FOR A
REASON.
I CAN SEE BOTH SIDES OF THE
ARGUMENT.
I THINK IT IS TIME YOU DIVE INTO
THOSE ARGUMENTS IF THAT'S THE
CASE.
>> CONNOR, LET ME GET INTO THE
COMMENTS AND SEE WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
I GOT ALEX FROM NORTHEAST L.A.
THAT IS HIS USER NAME, GREG.
NORTHEAST L.A. SAYS KENDRICK
BOURNE AND HE HAS A BELICHICK
GIF WITH A WINK.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, NORTHEAST L.A.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I ALSO GOT AGGIE S156.
THEY GOT A KENDRICK BOURNE GIT.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
AT THE BOTTOM HERE, I GOT I WANT
TO WIN.
A.J. DILLON TO STEAL JONES TD AT
THE GOAL LINE.
OKAY.
YOU ARE ALSO WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, I'LL JUST CALL IT THERE.
HOLD ON.
ONE MORE.
ISAAC BOATMAN, A.J. ALL DAY.
IT APPEARS THE PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN.
A.J. DILLON.
A.J. DILLON IS MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
>> A.J. DILLON.
THEY ARE GOING WITH LUCY, THE
CHEESE LEGEND MOVES ON.
THANKS TO KENDRICK BOURNE
DESPITE OUR ADVICE.
I APPRECIATE WHEN THE COMMENTS
GO THE OTHER WAY.
ALL RIGHT.
ROUND TWO.
>> YEAH.
>> WE'VE GOT A LOT LEFT HERE.
THAT WAS A TIGHT ROUND ONE.
ROUND TWO HERE, AARON WHALES
COMING IN TO TAKE DOWN LUCY.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT HERE.
>> HERE WE GO.
NEW YEAR.
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
DIGGS VERSUS ATLANTA.
HEY, LET'S GO.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S RUN IT.
>> THE DICE LEGEND.
THE DICE SAYING GO FOR IT WITH A
GREAT SMILE.
HE'S LOVING THIS PICK ALREADY.
HE'S LOVING THE STEFON DIGGS
TOUCHDOWN.
YOU CAN FLIP THOSE ODDS UPSIDE
DOWN, GIVE IT A PLUS MONEY.
THIS IS A TOUGH MATCHUP.
DIGGS IS COMING IN HOT.
GREG, HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS
ONE?
I THINK I KNOW WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO GO, BUT HOW ARE YOU
FEELING HERE.
>> BEFORE I GET INTO HOW I'M
FEELING, CONNOR, BECAUSE I'M
FEELING REALLY GOOD.
BUT BEFORE I GET INTO THAT, I
WANT EVERYBODY, EVERYBODY IN THE
COMMENTS.
YOU GOT TO LET US KNOW IF WE'RE
RIDING WITH A.J. DILLON OR
STEFON DIGGS, CONNOR, WE TALK
ABOUT STEFON DIGGS IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERY WEEK, AND I LOVE EVERY
TIME WE TALK ABOUT THIS WIDE
RECEIVER.
WE ALL KNOW THAT HE'S JOSH
ALLEN'S FAVORITE TARGET OUT
THERE IN BUFFALO.
JOSH ALLEN, HE FEEDS STEFON
DIGGS REGULARLY.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, MY GUY
SCORED, CONNOR, HE SCORED IN HIS
LAST TWO GAMES.
SO HE'S ON A TOUCHDOWN STREAK.
THEY'RE GETTING THAT CONNECTION
READY FOR THE PLAYOFFS.
THEY'RE TAKING ON AN ATLANTA
FALCONS DEFENSE THAT SCARES
NOBODY.
THEY DON'T SCARE ME, CONNOR.
AND THEY'RE RANKED 23rd IN
PASSING YARDS.
SO I LIKE THIS ONE.
I LIKE THE LEAN KEFEN DIGGS
HERE.
>> YEAH.
I GOT TO GO WITH THE SAFE PLAY
AS WELL.
I LOVE WHAT A.J. TERRELL HAS
DONE WITH THE FALCONS.
BUT YOU SAID IT, GREG, THOSE
OVERALL STATS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES.
THIS DEFENSE DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
EVEN WITH HOW GOOD TER RIL HAS
BEEN.
EVEN IF HE DOES, BRIAN WITH THE
BILLS, THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
STEAM HIM OPEN.
HE CAN GET OPEN ON HIS OWN.
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST ROUTE
RUNNERS IN THE NFL.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT DEFENSE
IS OUT THERE.
OBVIOUSLY ATLANTA IS NOT A GREAT
ONE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT DEFENSE
IS OUT THERE.
WHEN JOSH ALLEN IS ON, HE CAN
MAKE PLAYS WITH HIS LEGS.
HE CAN MAKE ANY THROW.
I LOVE DIGGS HERE.
I'M WITH YOU ON THE LAST POINT.
THEY ARE FROM THE LAST SEGMENT.
I WORRY ABOUT A.J. DILLON'S
TOTAL CARRIES.
AS MUCH AS I LOVE COLD WEATHER
IN THAT HE CAN PUNCH IT IN, I
LOVE STEFON DIGGS THIS WEEK.
>> I LIKE STEFON DIGGS.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE COMMENTS ARE
SAYING.
I'M SEEING A LOT OF STEFON DIGGS
GIFs.
>> IT'S A WASTE OF TIME.
YOU KNOW WHERE THIS ONE IS GOING
TO GO.
CONNOR, ALL RIGHT, I DON'T WANT
TO WASTE TIME, BUT I GOT TO GET
PEOPLE -- I GOT TO GET PEOPLE
HOODIES.
THAT'S WHY THEY COME.
HERE WE GO.
ELI -- OH, GOD.
ELI BEZOB PRODUCERS, YES, THAT'S
WHAT IT IS, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
HE PUT STEFON DIGGS.
ALSO GOT -- I GOT DREW AZAROBA.
LOCK IT IN DIGGS ALL THE WAY.
ONE MORE COMMENT AND THEN WE'RE
GETTING OUT OF HERE.
HE SAID STEFON DIGGS.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY.
YOU ALL ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
CONNOR, LIKE YOU SAID, WE DID
NOT NEED TO GO TO THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW WHO'S WON
THIS MATCHUP.
BUT I WILL OFFICIALLY SAY IT.
STEFON DIGGS IS MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
>> YOU DID THE RIGHT THING.
GOT TO GIVE THE PEOPLE THEIR
LOVE.
BUT STEFON DIGGS IN A RUN-AWAY.
I'M SORRY, LUCY.
ALL RIGHT.
ROUND THREE, FINAL ROUND.
IT IS PRETTY TOUGH TO KNOCK OFF
STEFON DIGGS IN MY OPINION.
WE MIGHT HAVE TO LOOK TO A LONG
TIME SQUAD RIDE LEGEND TO AT
LEAST GIVE IT A FIGHT.
WE'RE DIALING IT UP.
>> OH.
>> WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE'VE GOT COOPER KUPP AND DAMIEN
HARRIS.
WANT TO SEE WHICH ONE.
OH.
IT'S LOOKING LIKE A COOPER KUPP.
COOPER KUPP KIND OF WEEK.
>> COOPER KUPP.
COOPER KUPP, HE'S GOT ONE OF THE
BEST MATCHUPS OF THE WEEK RIGHT
HERE.
HE'S BEEN THE BEST PPR FANTASY
PLAYER, THE BEST.
THE BEST PPR FANTASY PLAYER.
HE'S GETTING IN THE END ZONE.
STEFON DIGGS STILL LIKING IT.
THIS IS AS GOOD A FINAL MATCHUP
AS WE CAN ASK FOR.
YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO.
TELL THEM WHAT WE NEED.
>> PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS,
EVERYBODY THAT'S WATCHING, WHAT
I NEED YOU TO DO IS GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND LET US KNOW.
IF WE SHOULD ROCK WITH COOPER
KUPP, IF WE SHOULD ROCK WITH
STEFON DIGGS OR IF WE SHOULD
ROCK WITH BOTH BECAUSE THAT IS
THE WAY I'M LEANING.
I LIKE BOTH OF THESE PICKS AND
I'M TORN ON WHICH ONE I WANT TO
WIN THIS TOURNAMENT.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT COOPER
KUPP.
HE DID NOT SCORE LAST WEEK,
CONNOR.
HE WENT FOR TEN AND 109.
109 YARDS OFF OF 10 RECEPTIONS,
BUT HE DID NOT SCORE.
THAT BROKE A STREAK.
HE SCORED IN THREE PREVIOUS
WEEKS BEFORE THAT.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE FOURTH
WEEK THAT BROKE THE STREAK.
DO NOT BE ALARMED, EVERYBODY.
I THINK THE STREAK IS GOING TO
START AGAIN THIS WEEK AND SIMPLY
BECAUSE -- I'LL LEAVE IT ON T
S
THIS -- THEY'RE FACING THIS
RAVENS TEAM THAT ARE BANGED UP.
THEY HAVE PRACTICE SQUAD PLAYERS
OUT THERE PLAYING DEFENSE.
I LIKE MY CHANCES WITH COOPER
KUPP.
GIVE ME COOPER KUPP TO SCORE.
I ALSO LIKE STEFON DIGGS, SO I
REALLY DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY,
CONNOR.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEADING?
>> YOU CANNOT GO WRONG HERE,
RIGHT?
WE'RE JOKING THAT YOU CAN PARLAY
THEM BOTH.
CAN YOU BOOST THE PARLAY?
I LOVE DIGGS.
I LOVE KUPP, BUT YOU ARE
SPEAKING GOSPEL.
YOU NAILED IT.
COOPER KUPP HAS THE BEST
MATCHUP. THIS IS THEIR REAL
DEFENSE.
THEY'RE DOWN AND OUT, NUMBER
ONE, TWO, THREE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
BUT SPECIFICALLY IN THAT
SECONDARY IN A DEFENSE THAT'S
DRAWN UP BY WINK MARTINDALE, AND
IT PUTS A LOT OF PRESSURE ON THE
CORNERS ON THE BACK END TO HOLD
UP IN COVERAGE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THEIR TOP GUYS
TO DO THAT.
AND CERTAIN TEAMS AGAINST YOUNG
QUARTERBACKS, YOU CAN SUCCEED IN
DOING THAT.
IT IS A TOUGH TASK.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY.
SO I LOVE COOPER KUPP.
I REALLY, REALLY LIKE STEFON
DIGGS.
I LOVE COOPER KUPP THIS WEEK.
LET THEM TAKE US HOME.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE MAD WITH
EITHER SELECTION HERE.
>> I LIKE WHAT YOU DID THERE,
CONNOR.
YOU SAID LET THEM TAKE US HOME.
I GOT M. KENT 93.
HE HAS A STEFON DIGGS GIF AND
HE'S LAUGHING.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ISAAC BOATMAN IS BACK IN THE
COMMENTS ASKING IF WE CAN'T HAVE
BOTH.
YEAH, WHY DON'T WE HAVE BOTH.
PARLAY THEM, IN FACT.
BRIAN, THE REAL BUTTA 53 SAYS
ONLY ONE CHOICE.
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE, AND HE HAS
A GIF OF JARED GOFF.
IS THAT JARED GOFF OR IS THAT
COOPER KUPP?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S JARED
GOFF.
THAT'S CONTROVERSY THERE.
THAT LOOKS LIKE JARED GOFF, BUT
HE'S APPEARING AT COOPER KUPP.
OR HE'S SAYING IT'S COOPER KUPP.
SO SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU A HOODIE FOR THAT.
OKAY, CONNOR, I'M GOING TO MAKE
A DECISION.
NEXT ONE I SEE I'M JUST GOING TO
MAKE A DECISION.
PHK1RKS SAYS YOU ALREADY KNOW.
THIS ONE ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE
COOPER KUPP.
THIS IS A GIT OF COOPER KUPP
GIVING US THE SHRUGS E MOWY.
I WILL MAKE THE DECISION RIGHT
THERE.
IT APPEARS WE ARE ALL RIDING
WITH COOPER KUPP TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
LET ME SHOW YOU GUYS SOME MAGIC.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC,
PLEASE.
AND THERE IT IS.
UP TOP, POOF, THERE'S THE MAGIC.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT
DRAFTKINGS.
WE'RE GOING TO BOOST THAT FROM
MINUS 165 TO PLUS 110.
YES, THIS IS PLUS MONEY FOR A
COOPER KUPP TOUCHDOWN.
CHECK OUT SOCIALS FOR A LINK.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND YOUR
CELEBRATIONS, BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, WE WANT WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE, CONNOR.
>> LET'S GET IT DONE, MAN.
LET'S GET IT DONE.
STEFON DIGGS, I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE A WINNER.
LOVE WHAT YOU DID WITH THOSE
ADDS THERE.
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY GETS
DRAFTKINGS.
SPEAKING OF WINNERS, WE ARE NOT
DONE.
COMMUNITY CONTENT CONTEST TIME.
WE'RE ASKING YOU SOMETHING
DIFFERENT EVERY WEEK ON SOCIAL.
WE'RE ASKING YOU IN THIS
BLEACHER REPORT APP.
WHO ARE YOU BETTING ON TO BE ONE
OF THE FINAL PLAYOFF TEAMS?
WHO IS ON THE OUTSIDE LOOKING IN
AND IS GOING TO PUNCH THROUGH OR
IS GOING TO HOLD DOWN THAT SPOT?
WHO IS GOING TO GET IT DONE IN
THESE LAST TWO WEEKS?
SO, GREG, WHO ARE PEOPLE RIDING
WITH?
WHO ARE THEY HAVING THEIR BELIEF
IN IN WEEK 17 AND THEN 18?
>> WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO,
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO IS
YOU GUYS LET ME KNOW WHICH
COMMENT YOU GUYS LIKE BETTER.
THAT PERSON WILL BE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
CONNOR, ARE YOU READY?
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> I THINK WE CAN JUMP RIGHT
INTO IT.
LET'S JUMP RIGHT INTO IT.
MY GUY KELLY LACY SAYS THE
CHARGERS WILL BE IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
WOW, CONNOR.
HE SAYS THE CHARGERS WILL BE IN
THE PLAYOFFS.
THEY JUST BEEN SO INCONSISTENT
FOR ME.
I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN AGREE WITH
THIS.
WHY ARE WE EVEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS, CONNOR?
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THE
CHARGERS?
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN -- THEY
SHOULD HAVE STAMPED THEIR WAY
INTO THE PLAYOFFS.
CONNOR, HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THIS?
>> KELLY, I'M SORRY.
AND I LOVE THE CONFIDENCE IN
YOUR SQUAD RIGHT HERE SAYING
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
BUT, GREG, I'M WITH YOU.
THEY HAVEN'T GIVEN US A REASON
TO TRUST THEM YET, RIGHT?
WE LOVE JUSTIN HERBERT.
WE LOVE THE WEAPONS THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVE DEALT WITH COVID AS
MUCH AS EVERYBODY.
HE'S BEEN ONE OF THE BETTER
ROOKIE HEAD COACHES, BUT IT'S
BEEN UP AND DOWN.
BUT THEY CONTROL THEIR DESTINY
ESSENTIALLY AND THEY GOT
WALLOPED BY THE TEXANS LAST
WEEK.
THE TEXANS, GREG.
THIS IS A GAME YOU'VE GOT TO
WIN, ESPECIALLY IN CRUNCH TIME.
SO I THINK THE CHARGERS SCHEDULE
ON THE WAY OUT, STARTING WITH
THE BRONCOS TODAY IS FAVORABLE.
IT IS FAVORABLE FOR THEM TO GET
TO TEN WINS, FINISH 10-7, MAKE
THE PLAYOFFS AND THEN YOU CAN
MAKE SOME NOISE WITH YOUR YOUNG
QUARTERBACK.
BUT I HAVE ONE RULE IN BETTING
AND IN FOOTBALL IN GENERAL.
IF YOU HAVEN'T GIVEN ME A REASON
TO TRUST YOU, WHY SHOULD I START
RIGHT NOW?
I'M SORRY.
THE CHARGERS FALL UNDER THAT
BUCKET.
>> YEAH.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS ONE,
KELLY, BUT LET'S SEE WHAT THE
NEXT ONE HOLDS, CONNOR.
WE GOT JODY THE KID WHO SAYS IF
BALTIMORE GETS THIS UPSET ON
SUNDAY, THEY CAN DEFINITELY
SQUEEZE IN.
I AGREE HERE.
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE HERE.
IF THEY CAN SOMEHOW, CARTER, IF
THEY CAN SOMEHOW GET A WIN TODAY
AGAINST THE RAMS, THEY CAN
SQUEEZE IN THE PLAYOFFS.
THIS ONE IS ACTUALLY CORRECT, IN
MY OPINION.
WHICH WAY DO YOU FEEL?
HOW DO YOU FEEL, CONNOR?
>> I THINK IT'S A GOOD CAVEAT,
YEAH.
WHAT MATTERS IS TODAY.
PULL OFF THE UPSET AGAINST THE
RAMS AND OUR LACK OF FAITH
INDICATES WE THINK THEY PROBABLY
WON'T BE ABLE TO DO IT UNLESS
LAMAR DOES SOMETHING REALLY,
REALLY SPECIAL.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN LAMAR HEALTHY IN
A WHILE NOW.
HE'S RIGHT.
JODY THE KID, YOU'RE SPOT ON.
IF YOU WIN TODAY, I THINK YOU GO
HOME AND BEAT THE STEELERS AND
BALTIMORE.
I THINK THE ENERGY WOULD BE
GREAT.
I THINK THEY WILL BE GETTING A
LITTLE HEALTHY AT THAT TIME.
WITH ALL THE CHIPS ON THE TABLE,
THEY WOULD GET IT DONE.
BUT IT'S A TOUGH MATCHUP FOR
THEM TODAY.
THEY GOT TO GET THROUGH STEP
ONE.
THIS COMMENT IS NOT WRONG.
I WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR.
>> COMMENT IS NOT WRONG.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE IF THEY
THINK THAT IF MY GUY JOSIE IS
WRONG OR IF HE'S RIGHT.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
LOTS UNDERWATER SAYS THIS IS A
GREAT SHOW.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU FOR THE GOOD
VIBES.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT -- OKAY.
THEY'RE ALL OVER THE PLACE IN
THE COMMENTS.
THE CHIEFS, CHILL, THEY AIN'T
BEATING THE RAMS.
CHILL, THEY NOT BEATING THE
RAMS.
BEN MAN 56 SAYS LAMAR SHOULDN'T
PLAY TODAY.
CONNOR, THEY'RE ALL OTHER THE
PLACE IN THE COMMENTS.
BENGALS ARE HOT.
AK BLUES TALKING ABOUT THE
BENGALS.
WE GOT ADAM SAYING, WITH THE WIN
TODAY PHILLY IS GOING ALL THE
WAY.
LOOK, THEY'RE ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
GUESS WHAT?
I'M GOING TO MAKE A DECISION
HERE.
I AM GOING TO MAKE A DECISION.
CONNOR, I LIKE WHAT JODY SAID
BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
BALTIMORE SOME HOW, SOME WAY
GETS THE UPSET AGAINST THE RAMS.
THEY CAN DEFINITELY SQUEEZE IN.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH MY GUY,
JODY.
JODY, YOU ARE WALKIN INING AWAY
A HOODIE.
I THINK IT IS TIME FOR THEIR
FAVORITE PART OF THE SHOW.
>> YEAH.
I THINK WE'RE GETTING THERE.
WE GOT TO KNOCK OUT SOME PROPS
FIRST.
IT IS TIME FOR PROP LOCK OR DROP
IT.
YOU GUYS LET US KNOW IF YOU LIKE
THE PROP, YOU'RE GOING TO LOCK
THE PROP OR YOU WANT TO DROP THE
PROP.
GREG, WHAT ARE WE STARTING WITH
THIS WEEK?
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
IF YOU THINK EACH PROP IS A LOCK
OR IF WE SHOULD DROP IT.
I'M GIVING HOODIES TO MY
FAVORITE COMMENT TER.
LET'S START WITH JONATHAN
TAYLOR.
TWO RUSH FOR OVER 107.5 RUSHING
YARDS TODAY.
CONNOR, HE LEADS THE NFL IN
RUSHING YARDS WITH 1,626 YARDS.
THE RAIDERS HAVE NOT GIVEN UP
MORE THAN 80 YARDS IN THE GROUND
IN THE PAST TWO GAMES.
THE COACH CAN ALSO CLINCH A
PLAYOFF BIRTH WITH A WIN TODAY.
I'M HONESTLY THROWN OFF WITH THE
SECOND STATISTICS I JUST SAID.
THE RAIDERS HAVE NOT GIVEN UP
MORE THAN 89 YARDS ON THE
GROUND, BUT IS THAT CHANGING
TODAY, CONNOR?
IS THAT CHANGING TODAY?
>> NO.
STEPHEN A. SMITH ONCE FAMOUSLY
SAID, GREG, WE DON'T CARE.
WE DO NOT CARE WHAT THE RAIDERS
HAVE DONE IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
IT DOES NOT WATER.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
RAIDERS HAVE DONE.
JONATHAN TAYLOR HAS GONE OVER
THIS NUMBER IN THE LAST THREE
WEEKS.
THIS MIGHT BE IRON MEETING IRON
RIGHT NOW, BUT I'M GOING TO ROLL
WITH J.T.
CARSON WENTZ, IT SEEMS LIKE HE'S
GOING TO BE CLEARED IN TIME TO
PLAY.
THIS IS -- THE COLTS HAVE THE
PLAYOFFS IN SITE.
RIGHT?
THERE IS THAT LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TABLE.
YOU DO WHAT YOU KNOW BEST.
YOU DO WHAT YOU DO BEST, AND
THAT IS TURN AROUND, HAND THE
BALL TO JONATHAN TAYLOR OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SO JONATHAN TAYLOR SMASH OVER
107.5 YARDS.
>> YEAH.
I'M RIGHT THERE BEHIND YOU,
CONNOR.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE OAKLAND
RAIDERS DEFENSE.
I'M HONESTLY SURPRISED THEY
HAVEN'T GAVE UP MORE THAN 89
YARDS.
I'M HONESTLY SURPRISED THAT THE
RAIDERS DEFENSE HAVE BEEN
STIFLING THE RUN.
BUT, YEAH, THAT'S CHANGING THIS
WEEK.
JONATHAN TAYLOR, HE'S IN MVP
DISCUSSIONS FOR A REASON, GUYS.
HE'S IN MVP DISCUSSIONS FOR A
REASON.
HE HAS A BIG GAME TODAY.
AND THEY STAMPED THEIR WAY INTO
THE PLAYOFFS.
SO I'M LOCKING THAT ONE.
LET'S MOVE ON.
ACTUALLY, CONNOR, ACTUALLY THE
PRODUCER JUST WHISPERED IN MY
EAR, GIVE AWAY SOME COMMENTS.
SO I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
AND J. TRAIN IS ROLLING TODAY.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
>> YES, IT IS.
>> YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> SAYS OVER, OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
HE'S ROCKING WITH THE OVER AND
YOU, CONNOR.
OKAY.
I GOT -- OH, YOU GUYS JUST SAW.
YEAH.
THE COMMENTS ARE LOVING IT.
OKAY.
I GOT ONE MORE.
I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
I LOVE TAYLOR, BUT NELSON'S OUT.
I MEAN, YEAH, STILL.
BUT IT'S THE RAIDERS.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT
COMMENTED, THOUGH.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED, THAT
COMMENT I MENTIONED, LET'S GO TO
THE SECOND ONE.
AARON RODGERS TO THROW OVER OR
UNDER 265 YARDS TODAY.
HE HAS THROWN 34 TOUCHDOWN
PASSES SINCE HIS LAST
INTERCEPTION AGAINST AN NFC
NORTH TEAM.
HE'S BEEN KILLING THE NFC NORTH.
0 INTERCEPTIONS OVER THE PAST
FIVE GAMES.
CONNOR, TALK TO ME.
IT'S GOING TO BE COLD THERE.
IT'S GOING TO BE COLD.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A LOCK OR
SHOULD WE DROP?
>> GREG, IT'S A TRAP BET.
IT'S A DROP.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE CLOSE, BUT
THIS IS THE TRAP BECAUSE
EVERYBODY LOOKS AT IT AND GOES,
AARON RODGERS ON CRUISE CONTROL
RIGHT NOW.
WE KNOW MINNESOTA IS IN TOUGH
SHAPE, ESPECIALLY IN THE
SECONDARY.
THAT GROUP HAS NOT BEEN GOOD
THIS YEAR, WHICH IS USUALLY ONE
OF MIKE ZIMMERS' STRONG
STRENGTHS.
THIS IS A TRAP, THOUGH BECAUSE
THEY DON'T NEED HIM TO GO OVER
THIS MARK TO WIN THIS GAME.
THIS MARK TO BLOW OUT THE
VIKINGS.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE A SHOUT-OUT.
IT'S FREEZING COLD.
BOTH TEAMS ARE GOING TO LEAN ON
THEIR RUNNING BACKS.
YOU WILL SEE PLENTY OF COOK.
YOU WILL SEE MADISON.
YOU WILL SEE JONES AND AJ
DILLON.
I WORRY, GREG, THAT THIS IS A
GAME THE PACKERS COME OUT.
THE DEFENSE CAPITALIZES ON SOME
TURNOVERS WITH SHORT FIELDS.
THEY DON'T NEED AARON RODGERS
DROPPING BACK 40 TIMES.
HE CAN GO FOR 230 YARDS AND 3
TOUCHDOWNS TODAY AND THE PACKERS
CAN RUN THE BALL OUT AND WIN
THIS ONE EASILY.
HIT THE UNDER.
TELL ME I'M WRONG IN THE
COMMENTS, PLEASE.
>> CONNOR?
NO, NO, NO.
COMMENTS, DON'T TELL HIM THAT
HE'S WRONG BECAUSE I'M ACTUALLY
WITH YOU, CONNOR.
LAST TIME THE NUMBER WAS SIMILAR
TO THIS NUMBER.
WE SAW IT AND WE WERE HAMMERING
THE AARON RODGERS.
>> YES.
>> WE WERE ALL OVER IT.
AND WE WERE WRONG.
THIS TIME WE SAW THE NUMBER.
WE'RE OBSERVING IT.
YOU'RE GOING UNDER AND I'M GOING
TO GO UNDER SIMPLY BECAUSE I
MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE SHOW
THAT VIKINGS RUN DEFENSE.
I THINK THE PACKERS WILL TAKE A
PAGE FROM WHAT THE 49ERS DID.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE A PAGE
FROM WHAT THE RAMS DID TO THE
VIKINGS LAST WEEK.
THEY RAN THE FOOTBALL.
AND SO WITH THAT BEING SAID, I
DON'T SEE AARON RODGERS THROWING
FOR OVER 260, TWO AND A HALF
YARDS IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE
RUNNING THE FOOTBALL AND IT WILL
BE COLD, CONNOR.
SO THE DOTS ARE JUST NOT
CONNECTING FOR ME.
SO I THINK I WILL DROP IT AS
WELL.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS AS WELL.
I'M GOING TO SEE WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING IN THE COMMENTS, CONNOR.
DORIAN SAYS YOU ARE WRONG.
THANK YOU, DORIAN.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
HOPEFULLY YOU ARE RIGHT.
BUT YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT -- I GOT UNDER EASY.
TRAP FOR SURE.
HE'S ROCKING WITH YOU, CONNOR.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT ONE MORE.
ONE MORE.
HOLD ON.
I SEEN IT.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO IT.
THERE IT IS.
DA
DAVE, HE WILL AT LEAST GET 300
FADE GREG, PLEASE.
YEP.
THERE IS IT IS TODAY.
FADE, GREG.
YES, YES, YES.
PLEASE LISTEN TO MY GUY.
BUT, YEAH, SHOUT-OUT TO YOU,
BROTHER.
I'M GOING TO SEND YOU GOOD
VIBES.
YOU SEND ME BAD VIBES, I'M GOING
TO SEND YOU GOOD VIBES, THOUGH.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, WE'RE DROPPING THIS ONE.
>> WE'RE DROPPING IT ALL THE
WAY.
WE ARE NOT DROPPING OUR BOLDEST
BETS.
BEFORE WE GET OUT OF HERE, THIS
IS WHAT WE DO.
WE DON'T CARE WIN, LOSE.
WE HAVE FUN WITH THEM.
GREG, LET THEM KNOW WHAT WE NEED
BEFORE WE GET OUT OF HERE.
I KNOW YOU STILL HAVE MORE STUFF
TO GIVE AWAY.
>> WHAT WE NEED YOU GUYS TO DO
IS TO GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
LET US KNOW IF YOU ARE ROCKING
WITH CONNOR OR IF YOU ARE
ROCKING WITH ME OR IF YOU ARE
ROCKING WITH BOTH.
GET IN THE COMMENTS, LET US
KNOW.
CONNOR, LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT,
BROTHER.
>> GREG, I COOKED THIS ONE UP
JUST FOR YOU, MAN.
YOU'RE STARTING WITH YOUR BOY
TREY LANCE RIGHT HERE TO GET IN
THE END ZONE WITH A TOUCHDOWN
PARLAY.
NOT JUST TREY LANCE WHO, LISTEN,
KYLE SHANAHAN IS GOING TO HELP
HIS YOUNG QUARTERBACK AND DO
WHAT HE DOES BEST RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S GET HIM MOVING, GET HIM
RUNNING IN THE END ZONE WHILE HE
CONTINUES TO GROW AS A PASSER.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS,
JACKSONVILLE ALMOST GAVE UP 300
RUSHING YARDS TO THE NEW YORK
JETS LAST WEEK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK NEW ENGLAND IS
GOING TO DO TO THEM?
YOU NAILED IT EARLIER IN THE
SHOW.
STAT GAME, STAT GAME, STAT GAME.
THE PATRIOTS ARE ANGRY, PISSED
AND WANT TO PUT THAT BILLS LOSS
BEHIND THEM.
GUESS WHAT YOU GOT SERVED UP?
FIVE COURSE EASY MEAL THAT IS
THE JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS.
THE PARLAY LOCK HERE.
WHAT DO YOU GOT FOR US?
>> I ACTUALLY LOVE THIS.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO IS
STOP.
STOP WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
TAKE A SCREEN SHOT.
TAKE A PICTURE OF CONNOR'S BET
OR GO PUT IT IN RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY LOVE THIS.
TREY LANCE, WE KNOW WHAT THE
NINERS DO IN THE RED ZONE WHEN
HE'S IN THE GAME.
AND DAMIEN HARRIS, LIKE I SAID,
STAT GAME FOR EVERYBODY ON THAT
NEW ENGLAND'S OFFENSE.
CONNOR, I REALLY LIKE THAT, BRO.
BUT THERE IS A GAME, THE NFC
EAST MATCHUP ACTUALLY GOING ON.
WE GOT THE PHILADELPHIA EAGLES
TAKING ON THE WASHINGTON
FOOTBALL TEAM, CONNOR.
I GOT TWO STAR RECEIVERS ON EACH
TEAM.
I'M GOING TO GO WITH A COMBINED
YARDS OVER PROP.
THERE IT IS ON THE SCREEN RIGHT
THERE.
DAVANTE ADAMS.
OVER 149.5 RECEIVING YARDS.
THEY HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
THEY HAVE BOTH BEEN KIND OF
STRUGGLING, BUT THAT CHANGES
TODAY.
BIG GAME, BIG-TIME MATCHUP.
AND YOU KNOW BIG-TIME PLAYERS
USUALLY SHOW UP FOR THOSE
BIG-TIME MATCHUPS, SO I SEE
THESE TWO PLAYERS BALLING OUT
WITH OVER 149.5 RECEIVING YARDS
ON TODAY'S GAME.
>> DIVISION GAME.
>> LET ME HOP IN THE COMMENTS.
>> DEVONTA SMITH COMING OFF 80
YARDS IN THEIR LAST WEEK'S
DIVISION GAME, RIGHT.
MAYBE HE CAN BUILD OFF THAT 80
YARD GAME.
WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT SCARY TERRY
CAN DO.
HE'S ONE OF THE VETERAN YOUNG
RECEIVERS IN THE NFL.
HE'S NOT HAD A LOT OF
QUARTERBACK HELP THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER, BUT WHEN HE'S ON, HE'S
UNSTOPPABLE.
IF YOU GET ONE OF THOSE GUYS TO
100 YARDS, IT'S GOING TO HIT.
>> EXACTLY.
EXACTLY, BRO.
EITHER ONE GETS TO 100 HAS A
GOOD CHANCE OF HITTING.
I LIKE THAT.
OKAY.
HERE WE GO.
RITCHIE THE COACH SAYS
WASHINGTON QUARTERBACK IS TOO
INCONSISTENT.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, RITCHIE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I'LL FIRE THAT ACTUALLY IN FACT.
SCARY TERRY HAS BEEN THE FADE
LATELY.
YEAH.
BUT WE'RE -- THOSE ARE BAD
VIBES.
THOSE ARE BAD VIBES.
BOTH FOR SURE.
WE DON'T WANT TO BLOCK HIM.
LET'S FIRE THAT.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU.
I GOT ONE MORE IN ME.
WADDLE JUST SAYS BOTH YOU GUYS
ROCK.
GOOD VIBES IN 2022.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT I
JUST MENTIONED.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
HOODIES.
OH, CONNOR, I GOT TO GIVE AWAY A
JERSEY.
I GOT TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY,
BROTHER.
I'M NOT DONE.
OKAY.
HOLD ON.
I JUST SAW ANOTHER ONE.
I GOT TO FIND IT.
ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
I'M GOING -- I'M GOING WITH THE
OVERANALYZER, CONNOR.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS,
BUT I LIKE IT BECAUSE IT
COMBINED US TO WHATEVER, BRO.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
YOU THROW SHADE AT ME.
I THROW LIGHT AT YOU, BROTHER.
>> THAT'S WHAT GREG DOES.
HE'S THE BIGGER -- THE BIGGER
PERSON IS WHAT WE LIKE TO CALL
IT, WHICH I RESPECT.
SHOUT-OUT TO EVERYBODY THAT
JOINED THIS SHOW TODAY.
SHOUT-OUT TO ALL THE LEGENDS.
I MEAN, WE HAD LOCKS GALORE
THERE.
I CANNOT FORGET BENNING WAS THE
LAST ONE THERE.
THANKS TO ALL THE COMMENTERS.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE OR A
JERSEY, DON'T WORRY, BR BETTING
WILL DM YOU WITHIN THE NEXT 24
HOURS.
WE WILL BE BACK DOING THIS NEXT
WEEK.
WE WILL BE DOING THIS THROUGHOUT
THE PLAYOFFS.
WE'RE NOT JUST DOING IT REGULAR
SEASON LIKE FANTASY FOOTBALL.
THIS IS THE REAL DEAL.
DON'T FORGET, COOPER KUPP
BOOSTED IN THE DRAFTKINGS APP.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS ALONGSIDE THE
MAN, GREG IVORY.
WE WILL CATCH YOU HERE, SAME
TIME, SAME PLACE NEXT WEEK.